hello everyone my name is Alexis King
I'm from Northwestern University and
today I'm going to be talking to you
about a programming language that I've
been working on for the past two years
or so in my spare time and just as a
brief disclaimer before I get started
the language is very much a work in
progress so I don't recommend that at
the end of this talk you all go home and
rewrite all your programs in Hacket but
it is to a point where now I can kind of
show off some of the ideas behind it
show you a couple of small programs and
some of the things that it can do so
before I get started I want to give you
just a little bit of context about sort
of where this language came from because
obviously there's a lot of programming
languages that exist and I used a lot of
programming languages but to really
stood out to me in my short time writing
programs and the first of those is
Haskell I wrote a school for two years
professionally it's a pure functional
statically typed programming language
there's a number of talks here talking
about Haskell so if you want to learn
more about it you probably can I'm not
going to spend too much time talking
about Haskell but it is a really
pleasant programming language the other
one is a language called racket which is
totally different and it's actually a
little bit difficult to explain it's a
lot of different things but the main
thing that people think of when they
hear about racket is a scheme descendant
it's a dynamically typed Lisp which is
obviously completely different from
Haskell but the thing that it's most
known for is its really really robust
state of the art macro system and so
what would happen is when I was writing
programs in Haskell I would find myself
wanting to have the macro system in
racket and when I was writing racket I
would want to have the nice type system
from Haskell so I said well why do I
have to pick just one why can I not put
them together and make a new programming
language so that's sort of what Hackett
is about and I'm going to explain over
the course of this talk why I think that
essentially Haskell deserves a macro
system and why specifically it deserves
rackets macro system but I'm also going
to talk about something else which is
maybe if you're already sold on macro
systems if you've already used Lisp like
languages before and you think that
they're great then I'm going to try and
sell you on why I think that macro
systems can benefit from a type system
in a way that actually hasn't really
been done before at least not not to the
extent that that
think it could be so before I get into
those two things and explain all of what
I'm talking about I want to give you
just a really quick peek at what some
actual Hackett code looks like today so
here I have a Hackett program hopefully
you can see that and it's not a very
exciting Hackett program it's very short
it's about 30 lines long and it
implements a restful web server which
again is not super exciting but I can
run this program and I get a server
running on port 8080 and just to
demonstrate that it does in fact work I
can say hello strange loop 20 18 and
there we go
it says hello strange loop 20 18 the
server can also do a couple of other
really simple things it can add two
numbers together so I can go in here and
I can say add 1 to 2 and I get back gets
back 3 again this is obviously going to
be an extremely popular web service and
if I put in some nonsense in here like
something that's not a number I get back
a nice error message and it can also do
things like calculate the distance
between two points also something
extremely important so I can say
distance between 1 comma 2 are actually
its distance from 1 comma 2 to 3 comma 4
and I get back some floating-point
number so again the program itself is
not very exciting or at least what it
does isn't very exciting what's exciting
is the program itself so to demonstrate
that this is in fact a statically typed
programming language even though it has
all these lispy parentheses I'm going to
hover over some of these identifiers x'
and you can see that I get some some
type tooltips so this has a function
which isn't very interesting because the
functions name is integer double and its
type is integer double but if we look at
something a little bit more exciting
like grete's this says this is a
function I defined inside this module it
has the type string to string this
number here has type integer and indeed
if I change this to a string then you
probably can't see it very well but this
this little dots in the corner turns red
and there's a message at the bottom that
says type mismatch between string and
integer and indeed it highlights that
part right there because that's the
location of the typer so that's
happening at compile time it is
statically typed and in addition to that
there's a few different things in this
program there's a really simple function
definition there's a data type
definition
there's some pattern matching and
there's also this def server thing which
actually defines in sort of a
declarative way what's the web server is
so it has three routes it has that hello
route add distance from and they're sort
of a declarative specification about
what data types it takes and returns and
then what function it ends up calling so
I'm going to go into parts of this
program in a little bit more detail I'm
going to go back into the slides but the
first thing I want to show you is that
Hackett really is fundamentally a
Haskell first and foremost it looks
probably not all that much like a
Haskell again it has all those lispy
parentheses but if you look past them it
really is almost identical to the
equivalent Haskell syntax so if you look
at for example the definition of a data
type in Hackett and a definition of the
same data type in Haskell again more
parentheses on the top but otherwise it
looks essentially the same the same
thing is true for pattern matching again
on the top with Hackett on the bottom
with Haskell some do notation like
Haskell Hackett has a monadic interface
to i/o and if you don't know what that
means that's okay it's not important for
this talk but if you do it's a little
interesting and type class definitions
so again Hackett on the top Haskell on
the bottom looks very very similar so
Hackett is a Haskell first and foremost
and if you are familiar with Haskell
once you get past the syntax you'll feel
right at home writing hackett programs
but of course it's not just Haskell
because if it was then this would be a
pretty boring talk so there's also this
def server thing and this does not
correspond to any feature in Haskell
which is probably a good thing because
it would be weird if Haskell as a
general-purpose programming language had
a language feature for defining restful
web services and this indeed is a macro
and I defined it in a little library
that I just implemented for demos and in
this talk so what is a macro if you're
not familiar with a macro that I'll give
you a really quick crash course in what
a macro is a macro is just the idea of
we wanted to add a new feature to our
programming language something that we
can't define just as an ordinary
function so this def server thing has
sort of it's a custom syntax it defines
a function called in this case run
server we can't implement that as a
function so it will do is will define a
translation from some new language
feature into some simpler constructs
that are already in our language in this
case just ordinary function definition
function calls pattern matching and we
do that
just by writing an ordinary function an
ordinary pure function from a syntax
tree to a new syntax tree and we just do
that in our programming language and
importantly this function is defined and
executed at compile time so the compiler
will find all the cases and macros in
our program it'll run The Associated
functions that we defined and then
eventually we'll get a program that
doesn't have any doesn't have any macros
in it and we can send that off to the
compiler and it works traditionally so
this is what a macro is that's really
all that a macro is there's more
complexities if you get into the details
but that's really essentially the gist
of it so macros allow us to abstract
over syntax and that's what's
interesting about macros because they
run at compile time they less abstract
over things that ordinary functions do
not and so oftentimes I sometimes hear
people say well Haskell doesn't need
macros because of some reason or another
but I'm going to make the case that
Haskell does need macros and indeed high
schoolers are asking for macros they
don't know that that's what they're
asking for but that's what they're
asking for so this this def server
example is one example of a DSL that can
be implemented using macros I don't
expect you to read this this is a
comment that I found on reddit about a
year ago that our Haskell subreddit
where somebody saying hey I have this
code I've translated it into Hacket
syntax so that I can show some things
off but otherwise this is essentially
what they were saying I have this
pattern I keep repeating this pattern
matching over and over again and I can't
abstract this into a function because
patterns in Haskell are not first-class
so you might say well maybe we could
contort this code to use lenses refactor
some things but with macros it's very
easy you can just define a custom syntax
that I have this pattern that happens to
be in my code I'll define a tiny little
macro for it and then I can abstract
over it and change it in one place if I
decide to change it at some point and
indeed this macro is very simple to
write in just a few lines of code in
Hacket so that's one example if you have
sort of this boilerplate that you can't
abstract easily you can abstract over it
with macros another thing that you can
do is this is an example that somebody
posted in a blog post also about a year
ago where they wrote these two functions
and these are two functions that take
boolean as a first argument and
importantly it turns out that these two
functions are mutually recursive and the
only place the boolean is actually used
is right there it's it's being used with
that if expressed
but because these two functions are
mutually recursive then the boolean has
to be threaded around everywhere and it
makes the code really messy and
difficult to understand because there's
all this extraneous information so the
author of this blogpost said wouldn't it
be awesome if we could add a feature to
Haskell called this section thing or we
could say everything in the section just
sort of implicitly has access to this
additional parameter now inside the
section form they just act like
functions with extra parameters but
inside the section form it's just sort
of implicitly passed around and somebody
on the subreddit again said actually it
turns out that we can implement this in
terms of existing Haskell features which
is really cool but there's a little bit
of boilerplate and so the author of the
blog post said wouldn't it be awesome if
we could get rid of that boilerplates
and indeed with a tiny little macro and
Hackett you can so this is really cool
because it means that macros allow us to
do a bunch of different things that we
can't do in Haskell natively high
schoolers are asking for them
specifically they allow us to abstract
over syntax they give us DSL is like
that def server thing they let us
eliminate boilerplate they let us
actually add features to the language
without having to change the compiler
just as a library and Haskell
programmers want them so hopefully at
this point in the talk I have convinced
you that macros are useful things that
that maybe you should want to use in in
your programs but now I sort of want to
explain why how can macros themselves
benefit from Haskell if you're already a
list programmer or you've used lists
Macker before how can this the
combination of these things be greater
than the sum of their parts so what I
want to discuss is it turns out that the
title of my talk is actually a little
bit of a lie it's a little bit
misleading the title of my talk was that
Hackett is a meta programmable Haskell
but there's a secret and that secret is
that Haskell is actually already really
good at meta programming if you use
Haskell there's all kinds of dsls that
exist already that are in widespread use
by the community one of them for example
is megaparsec it's a parser Combinator
library to DSL for writing parsers
there's a DSL called opt parse
applicative for handling command-line
arguments there's a DSL for creating
HTML and the one that I find the most
impressive is this DSL called servant
now what servant is is actually very
similar to the example at the beginning
of my talk which is a little DSL for
defining restful web services so the way
servant works is you start by basically
describing your API your restful api as
a type now this is kind of difficult to
read right there's a steep learning
curve but that actually does represent a
restful api so once you get over that
and once you can figure out how to write
that type down then all you have to do
is write a couple of functions on your
data types and you write a tiny little
bit of glue to glue the type and your
functions together and you get a restful
web server out of it and that's amazing
how is it that in just a handful just a
few lines of code we were able to get a
restful web server without the macros
that I was talking about earlier so
there's clearly some kind of
cogeneration going on here there's
something macro like going on here
despite the fact that we weren't able to
find a nice new syntax for it it's not
maybe as nice but there's something
really interesting happening here so the
secret sauce to all of this is type
classes so type classes are a feature of
Haskell and if you're not familiar with
them that's also ok I'm going to explain
what they mean the basic idea of type
classes is that type classes are a
mechanism for function overloading for
saying that if I apply this map function
to a list then it applies add one to all
the elements the list but if I apply it
to an optional then it applies it to the
value inside the optional and it just
gives me back nothing if there's nothing
there so fundamentally this is not super
exciting it doesn't seem like it would
have anything to do with meta
programming if you're a c-plus foreigner
you might see where I'm going but if
you're not then it turns out though
that's that Haskell's of support for
operator overloading is much much more
powerful than in say Java or some other
programming language that you might be
familiar with and so for example it can
be used to overload ordinary values not
just functions so for example this empty
value is is defined with a type class
and so when we say I want to use empty
as a list then we get back the empty
list and if I want to use it as an
optional then I get back nothing so this
is something that you can't really do
another programming languages but again
it doesn't really seem like it has that
much to do with meta programming
so in order to understand the connection
we have to think about what it actually
means to evaluate a program in Haskell
what does it mean to evaluate empty and
the answer is that we actually don't
know because we don't know what type
empty has at this point so once we give
it a type like saying I wanted to be an
optional now we know what this program
will evaluate to but this is really
interesting because it means that the
evaluation of programs in Haskell
depends on their types now this might
seem totally obvious of course it
depends on their types but it's actually
not obvious if you think of a lot of
other programming languages real
programming languages they usually
implement type erasure so if we take a
look at this this is some flow code
which is gradually typed JavaScript and
it has some type annotations and clearly
the the flow type checker is going to
make sure that the types are correct but
once it does that it throws the types
away and you just get an ordinary
JavaScript program so in that sense in
most programming languages types are
mostly only used for validation and I
think that that's a little disappointing
because one there's a lot of information
in the types the compiler knows a lot
about my program and I have to sort of
contort my program at times to satisfy
the type checker why can I not get more
back in return than just some basic
validation and so in Haskell you can but
again in Haskell the types like in those
other programming languages don't stick
around at run time they do get erased so
what's actually happening is that the
compiler is implementing a type directed
translation of the program using the
type information so essentially the
compiler is saying alright I see that
you're using empty it's supposed to be
an optional I will replace it with empty
on optionals and then eventually that
will get evaluated and it becomes
nothing now why is this interesting well
this whole detour is relevant because
type classes are there for compile time
functions from types to expressions and
this is really interesting because this
is kind of similar to what I was talking
about with macros earlier or macros are
functions from expressions to
expressions now we have compiled time
functions from types to expressions so
this might not seem that important
because if we just have empty and we're
using it as a list and we're writing
that type annotation down and it doesn't
seem like we're really getting very much
but Haskell has type inference so most
of the time you don't have to write the
type annotations
it just gets inferred so in this case
Haskell is essentially figuring out that
okay empty is a list here therefore I'm
going to replace it with empty on lists
why does this matter well because we
have type inference and type erasure or
sorry and type classes then we have
these two worlds' expressions and types
and if we have type inference then we
have an automated mechanism from going
from expressions to types and because we
have type classes we have an automated
mechanism from going to types to
expressions and this creates a genuine
feedback loop and we can actually use
this to achieve code generation which is
fascinating because this is not
something that you can do very easily
with a traditional macro system because
the type information just isn't there in
this case we're generating code based on
the type information that is known by
the compiler about your program
hopefully that made sense so what's
actually happening in this servant
example is that there's a bunch of
really horrible hairy type class
machinery that is picking apart this
complicated type and translating it into
expressions and that's what's actually
generating the server so in that sense
there's sort of a similarity here
between macro meta programming and type
class meta programming so what's the
difference why would I want both why
what why would I want both in the same
language how does one maybe do things
that the other one cannot so to give an
example consider the application of a
macro so like I was talking about
earlier macros are just functions from
code to code so a macro is going to take
some expression it's going to expand
into some bigger expression and this
expression that is passed is going to
end up somewhere in the output but
imagine that expression is just a
variable like X the macro can't know
anything about X because it's just a
variable so it's just going to be
treated essentially as a black box so in
that sense macros are really good at
local transformations where you have
something and it just uses the
information that's directly passed to it
but this isn't necessarily true of type
classes if we have some definition of
some variable X that's defined maybe in
a completely different module and then
we apply sho to it which converts it to
a string and use a type class to be able
to convert different kinds of values to
different strings then it's still going
to be able to figure out that ok even
though that's in some other module this
is being applied
to a list of integers and it's going to
use show on lists and then by sort of
inlining the definition of show on lists
we can see that there's actually another
use of show in there and so this process
is going to happen again on that use of
show now it's being applied it's being
mapped over that list of integers so
this is now going to be show on integers
and you can see how we get that feedback
loop that I was talking earlier about
how one thing then sort of expands to
another thing that then uses that type
information and we get that code
generation and so eventually we get this
this expression that converts that whole
thing to a list so to summarize macros
are really really good at local code
transformations they're not allowed to
look at other information about the
things that are that are provided to
them but we do get custom syntax because
we're able to manipulate the code tree
as much as we want the syntax tree as
much as we want type classes don't let
us do that but they allow us to use this
rich world and information that's been
made available to us by the type system
and this is really cool and and if you
write Haskell programs you see how if
you write Haskell programs and have also
used lisps you can see how some of the
DSL and Haskell end up being richer than
the things that you can write in a list
because of that information so the
question that I essentially had is okay
we can have a language that has both of
these two things together and we can use
them together but can we get both in the
same language feature can we write
macros that essentially have access to
that rich world of type information
arbitrarily in a more flexible way than
type classes can so essentially we
already have functions that translate
syntax trees to syntax trees but can we
also have functions that take a syntax
tree and a type and produce a new syntax
tree from that where maybe that type is
the type of the expression that was
passed to it so the answer is yes but
with some caveats so in order to
understand why this is hard we have to
first understand why implementing a
language with types and macros is hard
so if we look at sort of a idealized
version of a compiler if your compiler
writer you probably hate me for just
saying this is what a compiler is
but essentially what happens in every
compilers that is going to parse the
program into some syntax tree and then
it's going to ship that off to the
compiler and that's going to be compiled
to some binary bytecode so if we want to
add types to this compiler well that's
just a stage in-between right we parse
the program then we send it through the
type checker once the type checker has
said yep it's like correct then we send
it off the compiler we end up compiling
that program do the same thing as before
it turns out that adding macros to a
language is very similar we start by
essentially just inserting another stage
in between where we parse the program we
find all the macros we expand them and
then once the macros have all been
expanded we ship it off to the compiler
so a naive combination of these two
things would just look something like
this where we put the expander in front
of the type checker we parse the program
send it through the expander we get
fully expanded code with no macros
therefore we can send it to the type
checker the type checker checks the
types we send that off to the compiler
everything works well but there's a
problem with this can you see what the
problem is the problem is that the type
checker only runs after macros have
finished expanding and that means that
by definition the macros don't have
access to types because the types aren't
going to be inferred until after the
macros are have gone away so this
produces what I have been calling Lisp
flavored Haskell and it's not good
enough to me I mean it is useful right
you you get macros and types in the same
in the same programming language but
they're sort of just thrown together
there's not there's not this deep
interaction between them that I would
like to be able to get so in order to
have that what you really need to do is
interleave type checking and macro
expansion and this turns out to be very
hard and I did not come up with this
this comes from a paper that was
presented a little less than two years
ago at poeple called type systems as
macros if you want to read more about
sort of the general technique that hat
hackett uses you can read that paper and
hack it extends it and adds a whole
bunch of additional things to it like
Haskell style type inference and type
classes and all sorts of things that you
would want in a real programming
language but fundamentally that's where
the technique comes from and the idea is
that by interleaving these two things by
making so that type checking and
expansion are one in the same then we
can actually get type directed macros so
to give some example of why
we would want this and sort of
interesting macros that we can write if
we have this ability this is one example
of implementing GH C's typed holes as a
macro just as a library and I didn't
actually come up with this example David
Christensen who's currently in the
audience was the person who came up with
this and actually submitted a pull
request to add it into Hackett but the
basic idea is that you can write to do
bang anywhere in your program and it's
just sort of a placeholder and it uses
the information in the type system to
say what type is supposed to go here and
then it communicates that information to
the editor in some way that it can
display and say hey the first case you
need a string there then the second one
you need a function from string to
integer and the third one you need an
i/o action that produces an integer and
it turns out that implementing this in
Hackett is not that hard this I'm not
gonna explain all of what this means
it's outside the scope of this talk
maybe someday but essentially it's a
it's a short macro and you can do it and
you can actually get access to the type
information using the macro system so
you can also do other interesting things
like instantiation so GHC relatively
recently added something called visible
type application which is essentially a
form of explicit instantiation this is
not as fancy as that they did a lot of
really really nice things but this isn't
that required plumbing a lot of
information through the compiler this
doesn't this is just a library just a
short macro well ok short is a little
bit of a lie it's horrible I would not
recommend that anybody writes anything
like this but it is possible to do so
clearly we need to do some work on
making this information easier to use
but it is technically possible now
looking forward a bit I want to also
show you a couple of examples of some
really kind of more out there ideas that
you could maybe implement with this but
you can't implement just yet in Hackett
because this is still something I'm
experimenting with so here's an example
of maybe a macro that could be used to
generate cata morphisms now cata
morphism is a is a fancy word that
essentially just means a generalized
version of fold so if you look at the
bottom one it really is just fold on
list but it generalizes to other data
types this is something that's entirely
mechanical that you can generate from
the definition of a data type but
traditionally it's sort of obnoxious and
you have to write it yourself
theoretically you could do that with a
macro however not quite there yet
there's a few tricky details that if you
interested in hearing what they are talk
to me after the talk
another example maybe even more
ridiculous is maybe we could create a
macro that allows you to query from a
table using sequel and it uses the
expected type of what it's supposed to
return to bind variables that correspond
to the column names in the table maybe
people think that's ridiculous in a
horrible idea but I think it would be
cool if you could implement something
like this just to see if it worked
so anyway that was a lot of information
that I threw at you all at once but to
recap to summarize Hackett is a Haskell
extended with macros and this gives us
nice things it lets us extend the
language without having to modify the
compiler it lets us eliminate
boilerplate it lets us build nice DSL
with custom syntax macros allow us to
augment the metaphor facilities already
provided by Haskell it does not replace
them they work together in in a nice way
and type directed Macker are
theoretically available the interface
needs to be a lot better than it
currently is and there's still a lot of
work to do there but it's something that
because of the the inner leaf type
checking and macro expansion is
something that's possible in hack it
where's it's just completely out of the
question in most implementations of this
sort of thing and that's it any
questions
all right I am looking at slide Oh at
the moment and there's one question
there right now which is how does the
presence of Macker affect decidability
of the type system well so it's it's
very much because type checking and
macro system or macro expansion are one
of the same and macro expansion is
already undecidable you can write
arbitrary functions the type system is
obviously undecidable as well the type
system itself I guess isn't necessarily
undecidable it depends on how you kind
of define it
I think that's there's a lot of work
that needs to be done to sort of
theorize come up with a model for what
some of these things mean what does it
mean to have a macro system conjoined at
the hip with a type system it's not
something that has been extensively
researched but it's something that I'd
be interested in doing haven't done that
yet so maybe not a super satisfactory
answer but that's all I all I can say
all right so one other question
what does Hackett get us the template
Haskell doesn't that's a good question I
anticipated that it would be asked so I
actually have a couple of slides so this
is a question that I've been asked a
number of different times before but I
haven't really had a great explanation
for it in the past this time I do so the
basic difference between these two
things is the idea of macros versus
splices so some people would say the
template Haskell is a macro system I
would disagree but it is ultimately kind
of a fuzzy definition but what I think
of as a macro is something that
transforms code to code it has this type
that I talked about earlier template
Haskell doesn't have this it has splices
which take which are functions that
produce code and they are run at compile
time but they don't take code as input
why it does this matter well if you look
at the application of a macro like this
def server thing it's all able to have
any custom syntax at once a splice is
just an ordinary function that runs at
compile time so it has to still conform
to the syntax of Haskell so if you
wanted to encode that same thing on the
top in template Haskell syntax you would
have to write something really explicit
on the bottom which works okay in this
really simple example but when you have
really complex macros with optional
pieces to them and fancy grammars it you
really can't encode the things that you
would do with macros using a splice
but that's not all it turns out that
this type signature is actually a little
bit of a lie because in template Haskell
that ast that gets returned can't also
contain splices which means that you
have a really limited system where there
can only essentially be one layer of
splice transformation and then
everything has to stop that's really
limiting in terms of what you can do but
that's not all either it turns out that
GHC has a staged restriction which
basically says that if you define
something in the same module and then
try to use it at compile time you can't
you have to be in different modules
sometimes this is awkward if you end up
with kind of cyclical dependencies and
it's awkward to break them up into two
modules also you can't define a function
in or define a splice in the same module
where you use it which might not sound
like a big deal but then when you end up
doing really fancy Macker where you have
Macker that define macros and then you
use them it sounds ridiculous I know but
it is actually useful that doesn't work
with this kind of system but that's not
all either it turns out that first of
all Hacket handles that it turns out
that template haskell also imposes
various constraints on expansion order
so basically what happens is when you
have two splices at the top level of a
program
imagine make some data type is some
function that basically defines a data
type in terms of that has a field of the
second argument here so we're defining a
data type called foo that holds a bar
and a datatype called bar that holds a
foo normally that would be totally
reasonable to do in house call
doesn't work in template haskell because
the way template haskell works is it
basically just takes all of the splices
it chops up your file into chunks and
then it type checks them individually
and this causes problems because if you
have two things that refer to each other
it doesn't work and if you end up having
to you know have a situation where you
want to define something that's mutually
recursive you're kind of stuck hackett
handles that fine so there's a long list
of differences between these two things
and they really are designed to do
totally different things template a
school is not bad it's just designed to
do something simple simpler than what
hackett is designed to do it's very
useful i think writing tasks or writing
high school without template high school
would probably be kind of painful but
it's definitely it's a different thing
all right let's see other questions list
macros are easy in parts because the ast
is nested lists what's it like
manipulating the ast of Hackett's well
Hackett has list fee syntax for a reason
and indeed if you say look at the
definition of the expression in Haskell
this is the actual data type that
doesn't fit on the slide in fact it's
really big
this is just four expressions by the way
this is not the whole syntax tree this
is really hard to manipulate with macros
for precisely that reason it's it's very
difficult to predict what a particular
sequence of characters will translate
into in the ast and that makes it hard
to write extensible syntax with Hacket
just like in any other list but just
built out of lists identifiers and
strings and it's not it's not any more
complex to manipulate than it would be
in a traditional Lisp hack it does have
sort of in fixed syntax but it's
designed in such a way that that just D
sugars down into the the prefix syntax
and it's always explicit so it's not
difficult to parse it's a good question
I still have do I yes I still have some
time because I intentionally left a lot
of time all right so let's see what
would it take to use Hackett at phase
one that's a very racket specific
question if you're not familiar with the
racket two rackets phase one essentially
means that compile time so what would it
take to use Hackett's to write macros is
essentially the translation of that
question I think it's okay it's a good
question so theoretically not nothing
nothing prevents you from writing your
macros in Hacket itself so for a little
bit of context the macker that i've been
defining in hackett i've been right
using rackets to write the macros that
then expand into hackett code so it's a
dynamically typed macro definition
language that is mostly just because I
haven't got gotten around to
implementing like the the bindings the
the types for what it means to have
typed syntax transformers there's no
like fundamental reasons that can't be
the case it's just that I haven't gotten
around to implementing it and because
racket has a lot of really really nice
pattern matching facilities for handling
syntax and creating macros that would be
a non-trivial amount of work or maybe
not any new research per se to implement
in Hacket so there's nothing
theoretically that prevents it it would
just be some programming let's see a few
more questions
so macros can generate
Russians can they generate types
patterns yes and yes those are both
things that hackett supports is the
compiler slash runtime new from the
ground up or are you re using parts of
existing compilers for each language
it's a good question the way that racket
works is it's designed for essentially
adding new languages ghe is not so I'm
reusing a lot of racket I'm reusing the
racket macro system I didn't
reimplemented have to re-implement all
of the the GHC type system that's
unfortunately too different to really
reuse and again it's not really designed
for that sort of thing racket is so I'm
we're using a lot of the runtime support
from racket I'm reusing the macro system
and reusing the their pattern matching
system right now I'm reusing the whole
VM and runtime that they use but all of
the the sort of type checking stuff is
all new and built on top of that so
that's a lot of questions there's a few
more I think I'm going to let people
come and talk to me after the session
about those two those things instead of
forcing everybody else to listen to them
but by all means do so is still a bit of
time before the closing keynote and
thank you very much
[Applause]